another concern is with so many events
returning to las vegas
how can we keep the spread of the virus
under control i'm going to send it over
to kate houston who has
major venues how they're responding to
the issue kate
yes christian this conversation started
gaining attention after some people
posted to social media
saying they got the virus after
attending golden knights games
t-mobile was at full capacity with 18
thousand fans
i asked the health district about this
they have not traced any outbreak to a
game
but encourage those wanting to attend
these events to get vaccinated
as las vegas welcomes back major
concerts and events
only 46 percent of the eligible
population in clark county
has their first dose of the vaccine it
does make me nervous to
see that so many people are vaccinated
because they don't have on mass
throughout the next two weeks two
popular concerts will play at allegiant
stadium
and a ufc fight will be hosted at
t-mobile arena
while there are safety measures in place
some are wondering how closely they're
being followed by guests
i was expecting more and then when you
see virtually none
you know or less than 10 percent it kind
of got my attention but you know that
was yesterday afternoon i
kind of got accustomed to it mgm resorts
which operates t-mobile arena released
this statement
they're strongly encouraging employees
and the community to get the vaccine
fully vaccinated guests are not required
to wear a mask
meanwhile allegiance website states
those who are unvaccinated
must wear masks inside the stadium both
venues are following guidelines from the
cdc
but as covet 19 cases start to rise some
have mixed feelings on whether or not
they're comfortable in big crowds when
we're indoors
we have our mask on so we're trying to
remain
safe and but both of us are vaccinated
fully vaccinated but we still
you can still catch covenant well i am
very comfortable because i have been
vaccinated
and i feel very confident that i'm
protected from my vaccine
and so i'm i don't care really if
somebody else doesn't want to get the
vaccine
according to the health district there
is no current discussion about
increasing restrictions on venues or
businesses in the county
reporting from the newsroom kate houston
8 news now